I will say this the fight scenes that
I've seen are very good are you someone
who's comfortable in a fighting
situation where o op fighting I am
gifted athletically and my dad used to
pay the neighborhood kids five bucks to
beat me up yeah yeah uncle I grew up in
the hood end of New Orleans middle-class
nights really encourage kids to fire
because he knew it's a hard-knock life
man this is I wouldn't wish this on
nobody so he would pay people five
dollars to beat me up until I could
learn how to fight
so you know I lost my first three fights
hanging key but then after that I
figured out how to beat people up what
is that what's the secret you punch them
in the face if there's gonna be a fight
make sure that you throw the first punch
no no no no no you want them to think
they have the upper hand then when you
just rush them put your shoulder in
their stomach and put them down once you
get them down don't stop moving punch
punch
don't stop like you were robbing the
money
this is the Swedish in the south you
can't see me man the police gonna be
here in 30 seconds you can't see me so
you knock them down and then you
completely relax them that's it that's
it don't good that's it and I fight
girls - you fight girls yeah how did
that go over well I lost the first three
but they're like us they grow as they
get old no they grow faster I don't know
if they didn't like the chicken
McNuggets I don't know what it is but do
you think you think girls are taller and
stronger now I think girls are scarier
now yeah oh my god with that they got
all kind of tactics like they have the
new purse duffle bag thing you know they
got nothing in there except bricks then
when you like shut up you buy me a drink
they go
I figured that out about a third fight
yeah why are you going around a bar
saying shut up you buy me
that's the worst pick-up line
hey he a drink for rappers man I'm just
trying to feed him I'm just trying to
fit in